if i hear that anymore i'm going to be
singing it all day long please let's
never play that ever ever again although
it is it is kind of catchy uh maybe i
maybe i already will be singing it all
day long but the technicians love to be
singing it all season long hey here's
the thing chris 12 teams have never won
a super bowl and the texans at least
have the best excuse they're the most
recent team to the nfl from 2002 onward
they didn't make it at the playoffs
until 2011
and they've never advanced past the
divisional round they've won some
playoff games but they've never won a
divisional playoff game and
have they done enough this year to
complement one of the best quarterbacks
in the nfl you've got deshaun watson at
number five right is there enough around
him to compete with the other teams not
just in the conference but in their
division no i think that's a fair
question i mean that's what i worry
about more than anything i'm not totally
worried about their defense i think it's
very talented it was a little
disappointing in the back end last year
the texans defense as far as their
secondary uh but still the front seven
is pretty special they can overpower you
they did get guys like bradley robion
defense to sean gibson from the
jacksonville jaguars that makes sense
but is there enough weapons is the
offense do enough on that side of the
ball is the big question now a lot of
people like to just go first off as oh
billy o'brien you know he's only won one
playoff game and you know it's it's one
and three in his career well hey that is
true right but let's just he's he's all
in one with desean watson man he's
gotten to the playoffs with brian hoyer
brock osweiler it's it's it's actually
been impressive that they've gotten
there so i'm not going to knock him down
for the fact that they haven't won
playoff games to this point now if it
continues to be an issue going forward
with somebody like desean watson yeah
that'll concern me a little bit but
right now i'm still a big bill o'brien
fan i think this team is really good yes
but man they're in a tough division and
i don't think they're a slam dunk to
make the playoffs i just think they're
going to be in that conversation the
whole year and we'll see if they can
squeeze in
62 sacks absorbed last year by desean
watson i don't know that he can take
that kind of pounding again we had some
video of him earlier this week he looks
like he's put on some mass but i still i
don't care how much mass you put on you
get hit 62 times you get sacked 62 times
you're getting hit more than 62 and the
crown jewel of their free agent class on
the offensive line matt khalil vikings
fans panthers fans can tell you don't
expect that to fix anything
they used a first rounder on an
offensive lineman some thought it was
kind of a stretch and i i look that that
that is going to be what makes this
offense go whether or not they can find
a way to make the offensive line better
chris there's only so much you can do in
one off season to improve a bad
offensive line no no you're right there
is only so much you can do you know they
were banged up last year too so
hopefully just that health just being
healthy will make them better in general
and then yes if they can get the first
round pick titus howard or the third
round pick max sharping you know in the
lineup to where they can contribute to
or at the very least be really good you
know swing back up uh offensive lineman
have to fill in a tackle or guard or
whatever it may be that will go a long
way certainly uh but man the division is
the real deal and yeah i mean with
desean watson he took a lot of sacks
last year hey a lot is on his shoulders
they weren't a great running football
team he has to make it happen he doesn't
have a lot of weapons in the pass game
and because of that you know at times it
happened to aaron rodgers too when
you're under duress like that all the
time and it and the pocket can break
down so quickly mike you can't even
throw the ball away at times where there
was just plays last year with deshawn
watson it's just like oh man where can i
even throw this to where i don't get a
penalty or maybe i'm throwing it as i'm
getting sacked and i don't get it all
the way out of bounds and it becomes an
interception so there was some of that
too let alone yes he's still young and
learning on the job but uh i love desean
watson i really love billy o'brien
whether they make a big playoff run this
year i don't know if that's for sure or
not because that afc south being so
dangerous
it'd be really nice if they could
develop a strong compliment to deandre
hopkins one of the best receivers in the
world kiki qt a guy they've had a lot of
hope for but he's had issues staying
healthy will fuller has had injury
issues and
they're gonna they're gonna double and
triple de'andre hopkins the other guy
whoever it is is gonna have some
favorable matchups but a lot texans need
to do and the problem is the jaguars are
gonna be better right the cults are
gonna be better and the titans are still
going to be dangerous it's going to be a
rough year potentially for the texans
we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports